et retour sur une année à matignon pour
jean castex avec nos deux invités c'est
le débat de ce soir et nous sommes avec
gilles la case hannover re expert en
stratégie et communication et stéphane
rozès politologue président de cap
conseils analyses et perspectives
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce soir sur arte france
stéphane rozès
ces nombreux désaveu du conseil détails
vous semble anecdotique ou bien
révélateur d'une certaine façon
gouverner à la jean castex
je dirais pas forcément à la chan castex
ou en tout cas pour l'exécutif le
président mâcon et son premier ministre
le tempérament et l'idéologie de chant
castex par rapport à son prédécesseur et
d'être beaucoup plus prudent le bois par
exemple sur la question de la réforme
des retraites
là où edouard philippe était sans cesse
avoir alire d'un certain point de vue
plus loin dans les réformes
structurelles on l'avait vu lors de
l'assurance chômage ou lors des gilets
jaunes
il était sur le dur jean castex au sein
du couple exécutif est clairement
beaucoup plus prudent et c'est plutôt le
président qui est à la manoeuvre
comme si dans la perspective de la
présidentielle
le président avait besoin de donner des
gages qui ne fait des réformes
structurelles dans un environnement
européen où il pense que la situation en
allemagne va lui donner le la et de
sorte que les politiques de l'état
semble je dirais contradictoire avec les
grandes sa tante de la nation ce qui
fait qu effectivement le gouvernement a
tendance à aller un peu trop - à
franchir trop souvent lalime jeune mais
je dirais pas que c'est au ministre qui
est véritablement en première ligne
julian c'est plutôt le président gilles
casanova voilà un an maintenant que jean
castex est donc à la tête
matignon quel bilan tirez-vous de cette
année en hand a essentiellement marquée
par la pandémie déjà essentiellement
marquée surtout par le fait que le
président ne lui a pas laissé le moindre
espace
il a limogé son prédécesseur qui avaient
envie d'exister un peu et lui n'a vu le
moindre espace
il est resté monsieur déconfinement fils
est devenu monsieur confinement puis
monsieur déconfinement mais les annonces
ont toujours été faites à la première
personne par le président de la
république et l'article 20 de la
constitution qui dit que le premier
ministre est définit et conduit la
politique de la nation a été carrément
mis au placard et c'est le président qui
a tout décidé le premier ministre koné
apparu que pour faire une mise en place
technique et il est apparu
malheureusement un piètre technicien
puisque le conseil d'état l'a retoqué à
de nombreuses occasions et le président
lui-même vous vous souvenez que lors
d'un confinement déconfinement et il y a
eu par l'administration de jean castex
la production d'un document de dix pages
que les français devaient remplir s'ils
sortaient vous savez vous aviez droit 10
km si vous étiez à pied laissant votre
chien 20 km avec votre chien etc etc
ça faisait dix pages et c'est le
président de la république lui même qui
a fait savoir par voie médiatique que
c'était ridicule et qu'il fallait
supprimer ce document donc le malheureux
n'a pas eu la chance de montrer qu'il
était un politique peut-être les t-il en
tout cas les français ne savent pas et
vous avez vu que 60 % d'entre eux
interrogés il y a trois jours serait
ravi de son emplacement et en même temps
c'est bien jean castex que l'on a
beaucoup vu chaque jeudi pendant un an
pour ces conférences de presse
sur cette crise sanitaire les nouvelles
mesures à mettre en place
stéphane rozès vous disais que c'est le
président emmanuel macron qui est à la
manoeuvre
jean castex n'est cantonais qu'un rôle
d'exécutant il n'a pas sa marque de
fabrique
clairement le président ne voulait pas
au travers de la personne de jean castex
que se renouvelle au fond non seulement
des désaccords d'appréciation la marche
ils pouvaient exister entre le président
et le premier ministre d'autant que du
fait non pas du fond de sa politique
mais de sa façon d'être
le président le parlement le premier
ministre edouard philippe était assez
populaire donc évidemment le président
ça a été dit a voulu retrouver
l'essentiel des prérogatives sur le fond
est effectivement ne se privant pas
contrairement à ce qui se passait a
antérieurement de tacler par des écoutes
presse est ministre ou avoir le premier
ministre alors il est frais à la
décharge du premier ministre actuel que
ces allers-retours confinement
déconfinement lutte contre la crise
sanitaire lutte pour le le plan de
relance il vient de dire à satiété que
il fallait au fond
[Musique]
déployer le plan de relance alors même
qu'ils auraient peut-être un invariant
delta qui nous frères confiné à la
rentrée donc quand même la situation
évidemment n'est pas évidente mais
effectivement le premier ministre n'aura
pas appris mais ça m'a beaucoup se sont
demandés après l'échec de la règle quand
marcherait schena mets cantona mme
départementale pardon s'il ne fallait
pas changer de premier ministre le
président marc on n'aime pas avoir le
sentiment et de mes sentiments qui qu'il
a agi sous la pression indiquant même
l'éventualité à nouveau d'un nouveau
variant fait que la façon d'être du
premier ministre qui est plus dans la
résilience que dans le combat
finalement il a dû penser que tenterait
situation n'était pas stabilisé au
fallait mieux au fond le garder comme si
le variant d'un tas avait été ou sont un
allié pour le premier ministre pour
rester
j'ai le canada pour quelles raisons
selon vous au jean castex n'a pas réussi
à trouver sa place comme chef de la
majorité
lrm il vient de l herbe on le rappelle
pas quelque chose qui pèse aujourd'hui
encore parce que la majorité les re m
elle n'existe pas elle existe sous forme
de zombies qui au parlement vote
régulièrement au gouvernement
l'autorisation de gouverner par
ordonnances et on sait que c'est le
président qui décide de ces ordonnances
donc on est face à une majorité qui a du
mal à être comprises avec le pays
2,2 aux élections municipales puisque au
bout de six mois le ministère de
l'intérieur à a publié les chiffres là
on est autour de 6 à 7 points pour les
élections régionales
beaucoup moins pour les élections
départementales
on voit bien que nous ne sommes pas en
face d'une majorité dans le pays
nous sommes en face d'une majorité
certes au parlement mais dont les
caractéristiques propres sont de s'en
remettre au gouvernement pour
opérée par ordonnances sur les sujets
importants et puis jean castex
il n'a pas eu l'occasion de faire de la
politique
quel qu'en soit le prix quoi qu'il en
coûte ça n'est pas lui qui a dit cela
les décisions importantes au
structurantes que ce soit dans la crise
sanitaire
où que ce soit dans la réponse
économique à la situation engendrée par
la crise sanitaire
elles ont toujours été prises par le
président est le rendez vous
hebdomadaire du premier ministre et du
ministre de la santé faisait apparaître
deux personnes qui étaient deux
collaborateurs d'un niveau très
inférieur du moins c'est ainsi que cette
structure ex est apparu pour les
français mais emmanuel macron n'a aucune
raison de se défaire de jean castex
il est parfaitement diaphane
parfaitement grille il nous fait aucune
ombre pour la campagne présidentielle
qui s'annonce
alors que toute autre personnalité
politique qui serait un ou une politique
pourrait faire de l'ombre
pourquoi prendre ce risque pourquoi
aller chercher son manuel valls jean
castex qu'on a surnommé surnommé
monsieur territoire cette
caractéristique cette touche stephen
warbeck n'a pas réussi
alan flux et à la mettre en pratique
dans sa façon de gouverner
non parce que d'une part nous l'a vu
lors des dernières élections les
territoires doivent apparaître comme des
lieux d'instances politiques souveraines
et non pas comme des relais
administratifs d'un millefeuille
territorial et d'autre part autant les
français peuvent être inquiets sur le
quotidien c'est un acteur économique et
social autant de succès n'est pas en
france les territoires le sujet en
france c'est la france c'est ça souvent
et c'est l'autorité politique il ce
n'est pas la diminution de la france
dans des singularités territoriale même
si les français notamment au travers de
leurs municipalités sont très attachés à
leur mère le sujet central du pays
après vingt pendant la crise sanitaire
et avec des classements que nous
connaissons et notre des pressions
politiques c'est le retour de l'autorité
et la souveraineté politique
quel avenir politique est ce que vous
voyez pour jean castex agile casanova
après matignon est ce qu'il en a aucun
personne ne peut reconnaître en jean
castex une orientation politique
il n'a pas eu l'occasion la montre et ce
n'est pas entièrement de sa faute mais
la réalité est là qui est capable de
placer jean castex sur l'échiquier
politique on est capable de le placer
comme collaborateur du président mais
son côté territoire dit vous oui mais
enfin l'échec absolument fulgurant de la
république en marche dans les élections
territoriales ne joue pas en sa faveur
et il n'y a pas un seul sujet sur lequel
on puisse dire ça c'est jean castex
aucun si ce n'est que
eu le rôle de d'une personne qui
apparaît toutes les semaines comme celui
qui est chargé de faire tourner et
l'intendance vous savez cette intendance
qui se livrent à ces castex castex c'est
l'intendance ton quel avenir voulez vous
que les français donnent à un homme
politique qui leur apparaît ainsi alors
évidemment si il se mettait à faire un
éclat et à dire quelque chose de
remarquable dans un sens ou dans un
autre qui le distingue du président ça
pourrait tout changer parce qu'il a été
premier ministre
tout le monde connaît son nom tout le
monde connaît son visage mais personne
ne connaît cette figure vous partager ce
point de vue stéphane rozès a pas
derrière politique pour jean castex
après matignon et ce sera le mot de la
fin
et bien contrairement à son prédécesseur
qui était au fond la droite orléaniste
c'est à dire une droite dans la façon
d'être traditionnelle française et
valoir française mais sur le fond menant
une politique néolibérale et jean castex
au départ sa fiche est volontiers
gaulliste social ou n'aura pas pu en
faire véritablement la démonstration
pour les raisons qu'on a indiqué à
dentsu casanova tout à l'heure et le ce
qui a été indiqué de quoi qu'il en coûte
au plan européen et national est gagé
sur des efforts que les français ne voit
pas pour l'instant parce qu'il s'agit
d'abord de sauver le système économique
mais il est à redouter que au fond son
petit capital de départ de gaullisme
social s'il n'y a pas une réorientation
au plan européen n'apparaisse au fond
comme le masque d'une bonhomie dont le
coût pour les français après
les plans de relance risque d'être
difficile donc effectivement il
n'incarne pas une sensibilité précise à
l'intérieur de la droite
alors qu edouard philippe lui clairement
est un orléaniste rassemblés sur le fond
des réformes plus du nord que le
président macro qui oscillait entre néo
bonapartisme et orly et nice et voilà
pour le bilan d'une année à passer à
matignon pour jean castex merci à tous
les deux mais c'est d'avoir participé à
cet échange ville casanova expert en
stratégie et communication stéphane
rozès politologue et président de cap
conseils analyses et perspectives merci